for the moment I want to talk to a
gentleman who's been covering the Saints
for quite some time and he covers it and
talk some football in New Orleans Saints
for the athletic larry holder here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Larry
hey rich I appreciate you taking the
time because I want to find out best I
can as to what happened yesterday when
Drew Brees and the Saints met virtually
what happened yesterday best you can
tell Larry well look I think the the the
process even started before they met
where you know drew Brees put out his
apology publicly on Instagram you
started seeing players on the Saints
respond positively to that and look you
know you get into the call and you know
not a lot of people wanted to talk about
this on the record or anything you know
from from those I tried to reach out to
but they just said it was a you know it
was a conversation where you know it was
real life and look I want to understand
drew Brees apologized and what some
people have taken it well and I think
it's going to take some time still for
others to accept it and I think what you
started seeing kind of trickle out on
Twitter for those who want to do kind of
put it out there publicly someone like
Michael Thomas said look we accept his
apology and they want to see more and I
think that's that's the way it's gonna
have to be you know for for Drew Brees
right now and it's a rich it's really
just something when a couple of days ago
I see on st. Charles Avenue you know
where people celebrate Mardi Gras this
and the other and their protests and
there's video of bleep Drew Brees and I
mean it is it is a strong change of
opinion in this town much less just
inside the locker room and I think that
Drew Brees
you know I think he's genuine and his
apologies but I think he knows that he
needs to do more and his teammates in
turn
have encouraged him to do so and like I
think he I think he will do that well I
mean in terms of the raw feelings of it
all you need look no further than
Malcolm Jenkins is social media feeds
Malcolm who was part of the team when
Brees and Sean Payton did what they did
together in the city of Miami to bring a
championship to the city of New Orleans
after which you could say Drew Brees
would have a restaurant a restaurant
reservation at any time at any place for
the rest of his life Malcolm Jenkins
putting a fee a annum I mean a very raw
emotional video out that he said he
posted even after talking to Brees
because he felt the need to put it out
there and that's where I thought okay
this is different this is a serious
situation that's going down in that
locker room Larry yeah I absolutely
agree and I think Malcolm's emotions I
think part of is that he hadn't a lot of
respect for Drew Brees yes and that it
really hurt him because he he played
alongside with him views and like you
know the view Drew Brees it's almost
first a lot of people's eyes it's taken
a 1:8 you know he's someone who has you
know been relatively Scotchguard his
entire career and for this to come out
at this point in time really heard a lot
of people a lot of people that he
respected and that you know like I've
covered Drew Brees for 15 years and look
but here's the thing like his stance at
that moment in time did not surprise me
because that was his stance back when
Colin Kaepernick was with kneeling
during the national anthem and other
players were doing so a few years ago
but you know it seems that answe is so
rigid that it's certainly really taken
people aback specifically a couple of
guys like you'd say Malcolm Jenkins
Demario Davis both of those two players
and then
in the forefront and I will fit I will
say though that because that they are in
the locker room with drew brees I think
those are two of the most important
people that Drew Brees can talk to and
discuss this and move forward and and
try to mend fences really because there
you know this is this is something that
in so many people's eyes is gonna stick
with him as part of his legacy I mean
that's just that's just what this is
well I mean and and that's the way it
feels right now that's for sure and and
and it'll be brought up you know because
they're still there's still too many
people talking past one another Larry
and by that I mean a whole host of
individuals who heard what Brees had to
say two days ago and say well what's
wrong with him saying that he would he
would we wants to stand for the national
anthem and it's a call for unity for him
it's because what he said is that he
would never agree with anybody who
didn't do that meaning he hasn't heard
what his teammates who were kneeling or
were planning on kneeling said three
years ago he didn't absorb it and then
there are many people who were saying
well you know why are you people want a
kneel on a flag when they disrespect it
and it's just no we're not you know
you're still not hearing why they're
doing it and I you know breeze may hear
it when he walks in to the Nitschke
luncheon at the Hall of Fame the year
he's in you know he may hear it from
some truly old guard guys in the league
that he still didn't hear it back in
2017 and set it in 2020 so what do you
think what do you think he's going to do
I mean what what what do you think he's
gonna be about it Larry I know that's a
large question asked but I don't know if
you're hearing anything already about it
like I'm sure he's going to he's gonna
want to look he goes full bore and
everything he does in life whether it's
on the field off the field he needs
to fully all full-bore but here's what
one of the problems I think he's gonna
run into but look she's going to get
some of the respect within his locker
room back I'm sure they're going to be
people even in this side of the locker
room who are thinking well alright good
thing this is true reasons last year and
then we can move past this I mean
they're probably people thinking that
and then people outside of the locker
room who don't really know him are not
going to buy what he's going to be doing
and that is something that I don't know
the answer to that like I don't know how
he can change some people's minds who
have never played with him who have
never you know really taught with him
they just see him as this superstar
athlete who's you know you know a white
superstar athlete who's made millions
and millions and millions of dollars and
after he said this Hopf can he turn and
say this and you know so I don't have a
good answer for you rich I mean I don't
you know it's going to be come down to
each individual person if you think that
what he is going to do after this is
genuinely what he thinks and you know
that's something that I never thought we
would have to say about someone who is
so revered in this community
I mean he's you know he was bigger than
life in this community now all of a
sudden people are chanting bleep you on
st. Charles Avenue it's crazy it is
crazy also in the fact that I've got
some responses on my Twitter feed
because I've been talking about it or
our YouTube feed Larry oh by the way
Larry holder or the athletic Saints
columnist here in the Rich Eisen show
people are like well drew you got to put
your money where your mouth is it's just
like okay well a couple weeks ago he put
five he and his wife put five million
dollars into the community to fight
kovat 19 relief and now we'll see what
happens next so based on what you've
heard things were were what yesterday
raagh rocky and then smooth I mean is
there any any details of what anybody's
come out of that virtual meeting saying
that you cannot pass a ball probably a
good good way you know
and drew Bree I mean he's just yeah he
had to be sit there and apologetic and
basically shear out what people were
saying and I mean that's that's the best
way he could do it right now because you
know what let's be honest like you're
gonna have people that you've you've
really hurt badly that are going to
literally have to watch your back on a
football field and I mean you know
that's you got to start there and so you
know I do feel like that say inside this
locker room that people will respect the
clear views and and move forward and and
look battle it out on the football field
and and do that some people will take
that respect going forward and I still
think that maybe some people will never
do that ever again
and you know it's it's like I said it's
it's in each and individual thing within
the people within that locker room and
you know it's you can't it's hard to
argue with them either way like you know
what which way you do you want to go I
mean it's really just kind of up to what
you feel in your heart and what you feel
about what he has to say and the actions
that he's going to do and so well it's
I've talked to even former players
yesterday that weren't never on the
Saints is that and the other and they
said they have never seen anything like
this ever happened publicly so publicly
where your own turn you know really just
turned against you publicly for
something that you've done and I don't
have well I don't have all the answers
yet I don't know when we're going to
have all the answers and I think that's
you know but I do think you know that
that's to discuss it it also pushes a
discussion to be had in this community
and around the world you know just just
about everything that's going on right
now to be honest of course so before I
let you go um since I promised my
listeners and viewers and I mean it that
we're gonna go into the sports bubble
more today than we have in quite some
time with everything going on in the
real world prior to all this
conversation was Taysom Hill was the
next guy up when Drew Brees would move
on to NBC
is that the case so what's going on
there Larry I I do I feel like that is
that is going to be what happens and you
know it's it's funny you know a few
weeks ago we're talking about a tasty
meal and Jameis Winston and no one's
talking about Drew Brees and it's you
know that it's just so wild twist of
events but but I think all signs point
to taste some Hill even with Jameis
Winston coming in you know Jameis
Winston is under a one-year deal Taysom
Hill is under a two-year deal I think
Sean Payton's affection for taste and
he'll being that has just grown as we've
moved forward and I think Jameis Winston
you know is someone that they look at is
like Teddy Bridgewater who comes in and
if they need him just in case if
something would happen to Drew Brees and
he would get injured or something like
that that Jameis would be the same thing
as Teddy Bridgewater and taste and he'll
would assume the same role but Sean
Payton is extremely confident that
Taysom Hill can be their guy once Drew
Brees has gone and like I'm still under
the assumption that this is GRU Drew
Brees is last year so that not none of
this has changed and he I'm still under
that assumption yeah I mean my gosh
there's some people of photos he
shouldn't even be playing this year
because of what's happened over the last
24 48 hours I'm not one of them but
you're you're hearing you know I believe
Shannon Sharpe said that drew should
retire and that that and he's not
welcome there anymore or shouldn't be
regardless of his apology you go look at
the likes of that tweet of Shannon
Sharpe Martian a lot more like the tweet
like that your Bri she retired so I
think that kind of partially shows you
that not everything is smoothed over yet
so you know just that in and of itself
is just a small sign that not everything
is completely smooth though so then I
know Larry I mean my gosh so an
especially since it does not appear that
any face-to-face conversations they're
gonna be had and in the NFL until
training camp hits what are you hearing
about that before I let you go certainly
in the the state of Louisiana and New
Orleans was a a considerable hot spot
back in April as many cities and
municipalities
what are you hearing about the Saints
and Anna playing season because Brady
versus Brees is gonna be a week one
contest that the whole free football
world is now definitely gonna be tuned
into we knew they'd be beforehand but
for sure
lots of interest to see how the breeze
looks with his teammates in that game
yeah well as far as just than that I do
look I
I think Louisiana has done a really good
job of kind of calming down the Bukoba
19and and so people have done a good job
social distancing this out and the
others so and the numbers have dropped
considerably per capita since when the
first starter like you said it was one
of the hot spots but I still think that
the first time they get face to face
will be training camp look Sean Payton
was way out in front of that saying
let's let's be healthy and this that and
the other and so I don't think you know
that's that's necessarily going to
change much I'm curious to see if if
Drew Brees gets workouts together I mean
typically that happens yep I'm curious
to see if if he does that and if he does
I think it would be good ground for him
to have discussions with Michael Thomas
or Alban camara
or Emmanuel Sanders or players like that
who came out and certainly questioned is
a nice term to put it you know Ashton
his approach to his dance well it does
sound like some breeze would do right
like hey let's send a finding the
everybody that is something that he
would do yeah but we don't know yet
thanks for the call Larry holder once
again thanks for coming back on thank
you rich appreciate you having me once
again Regina that's Larry holder the
athletic